because i have all these [ __ ] cool
stories that are [ __ ] useless to me
what am i gonna
well when when am i ever gonna get
mileage out of the story when am i gonna
monetize my story
come on let's let's exactly let's just
commoditize it let's just commoditize my
entire [ __ ] life dude i love telling
the chess story because that's such a
[ __ ] cool story
and i know i never get any use out of it
yeah yeah and also people just like i
don't know
it's like adding layers to like to me i
love it when i get to learn more about a
creator and like their personal side
yeah i actually like
yeah and like i think that i don't know
i just also i'm just gonna [ __ ] say i
love [ __ ] talking
i love talking i just won't shut the
[ __ ] up i mean i would argue we wouldn't
have a podcast if we didn't like talk
true that's true that's true that's why
i can stream just chatting for like four
hours because i'm a [ __ ]
psychopath i guess i just i just won't
shut up i have
too many stories to hold i just want to
keep [ __ ] chatting [ __ ] yeah
i don't know i love talking and it's
it's great being able to
i love talking about youtube as well
because i think it's such a because you
never get the opportunity to do it yeah
you never because
all of our friends all of our family
they don't know what the [ __ ] we do
yeah and then i could talk about it with
you guys but but i pretty dominate every
single conversation we have
off of the podcast you know what i mean
so it's nice to just talk about it here
yeah and then you know we can just chat
[ __ ] like poopy poo poo stinky
you know in private you know we're sorry
for anyone who got into this podcast
thinking it was going to be like an
anime exclusive podcast yeah because i
know uh
on i think i think you two were worried
about that and i was like no dude i
wanted to be [ __ ] like chatting i
don't know like
i wanted i wanted to be like eventually
yeah
we start off as an anime podcast right
and then we eventually grow out
we can eventually maybe start tensioning
out but no right from the get-go first
episode we were like i'm glad let's not
talk about it in japan
let's talk about japan yeah but we're
really glad that you guys
have like kind of stuck around and just
enjoyed us chatting [ __ ]
like arguably more so than us chatting
about anime yeah i
i wonder uh i mean going back to the uh
previous topic is that like because you
hear a lot of advice that youtubers give
to people i feel like a lot of it's
pretty [ __ ] let's be honest
a lot of it's pretty [ __ ] like house
of like i mean don't give examples
necessarily but like how
how are they [ __ ] right there is there's
generic phrases that that youtubers say
and and we let's be honest we say it
because it's [ __ ] easy
like you mean what i'm gonna call like
the the convention panel
give me yeah give me okay give me the
most stereotypical and i'll i'll say if
these are the [ __ ] ones you know
stereotypical answers on
advice when someone asks you how to be a
youtuber just be yourself oh okay that's
that is [ __ ] terrible advice shake my
hair do you know how many people i know
who are insufferable you know
okay i have so many mates where i'm like
listen you're in a fantastic [ __ ]
mate but if you act like this on camera
no one's gonna want to yeah yeah yeah
you know what i mean you have a lot of
mates you're like you should kind of
come off as a dick
see because for me now i used to say
that just be yourself right
just have fun with it have fun with it
you know but nowadays i just make it a
meme because i get asked so many times
someone's like how do i how do you stop
becoming a youtuber i just say
i i mean are we actually going to break
this down should we give advice i think
why not because people want
people want to know [ __ ] youtube
advice and we may also like actually
give good okay how to become a
successful youtuber
from trash taste i feel like we say
generic advice because
there's a like i feel like the generic
advice that we give
is like the core of what it is
but it's it's [ __ ] useless to most
people it is useless because there's
only so much you can say
like a half hour panel it's one of those
things where it's like you know in the
show when the old man gives advice and
you're like
that's [ __ ] dumb yeah and then and
then ten years later when he actually
does it you're like [ __ ] he was right
that's pretty much the advice because
you're like it's completely useless to
anyone
starting out because that doesn't mean
anything yeah but when when you've been
doing it for this long it yeah
you it's it is the core like you said
yeah but the be yourself thing is like i
think that's the
the biggest like cop-out
it is a bit of a cop-out because you
don't
you're not yourself as a normal person
you're not
like uh a presenter you're no one
normally is a presenter or a personality
who's
made for like camera you have to you
have to get that and you do it by
forcing yourself to act maybe a little
bit more exaggerated than you normally
yeah
right and then over time maybe you get
way more comfortable and that does
become your kind of like default right i
don't know
because like be yourself to me is like i
guess less accurate than just don't try
to be someone you're not
that's true don't change your person
like if you are going to play a
character play a character that is based
on your own self
which is i feel like what like a lot of
us do online anyway you know what i mean
it's just like an exaggerated perfected
version of
ourselves yes that's what i say i say
like imagine you on your best day and
that is
you on every single one of these youtube
videos yeah that's where she should be
you know whether or not that should be
right like should you be sad on camera
and stuff like that it's like it's not
really about
that it's think of every single best
personality trait you have
and show that like make that come
through yeah
and so that does require a bit of you
know a bit of [ __ ] going on with your
personality you have to change it a
little bit
but i found as well that it made me a
better person in general than like i
the the things that were people liked
about me
became more prominent in me in my
general personality so
it wasn't more so that i was faking it
more so that the real me kind of
changed into a more confident version of
myself
and i you know youtube has a way
of really making you see your flaws oh
yeah oh yeah it's
it's a fine balance as well because i
feel that you know
it's it's not gonna like you know it's
not about like faking a personality
right because
if you it's exaggerating if you exact
but yeah but if you exaggerate it
too much agreed that's when people are
like then you become
doubt then you become that psychopathic
vlogger yeah then you become that
psychopathic vlogger who is like the
most
angel yeah yeah but then when you meet
them in person they're an absolute
[ __ ] yeah it's like sometimes in
conventions people come up to me like
wow you're a lot more
calm than in your videos and it's like
well yeah because do you get that
oh yeah yeah i mean i mean i am like
though if i'm [ __ ] crazy in my videos
or doing something stupid like i
genuinely am like that but
you can't do that all the time right
yeah like yeah
otherwise you're a psychopath yeah you
normally want
you're either a psychopath or guy fieri
right like you know in in real life it's
[ __ ] annoying yeah yeah in a friend
group and someone wants to [ __ ] be
the center of attention all the time
like
it's not natural to want the center of
attention all the time like it's totally
okay to be in a friend group and be like
i'm just not gonna say anything for five
minutes and i'll wait for my time to
join in
exactly and if you don't join in at all
that's fine yeah man you can just be
there
um yeah there's plenty of youtubers i've
met where you know you're like oh you're
totally different oh yeah you are not
going to say any names obviously but i
don't want to get in trouble we've had
our fair share
this is the ghost we have uh behind the
scenes unfortunately
yeah if the cameras weren't on we'd
totally just be saying names like yeah
that person sucks
it's because when you okay you see drama
and youtube behind the scenes sometimes
and you're like wow
everyone is drama no one knows about
that's kind of crazy
yeah so yeah every youtuber you watch
probably has some drama yeah it's just
about whether or not
everyone has dirt on someone else and
just about whether
they choose to monetize it that's so
true
that's like that's so true but everyone
has [ __ ] with other people
it's very natural i've had i've had
issues with other youtubers before but
i've always done it in private and i've
always
swapped that in private
yeah i guess going back to like general
advice on how to be a successful
youtuber i think
one thing that's not really mentioned a
lot is just
know who your audience audience is like
don't try to appeal to everyone
you know what i mean no because you're
trying to please everyone you're gonna
be disliked by a lot of people yeah
you're gonna be disliked by a lot of
people just just accept that
um i feel like one thing that not many
people think about
especially like even us when we started
we didn't really think about it we
didn't really think
oh i want to be this kind of person or
aim for this kind of audience
but it's something you kind of grow into
and now all three of us have very
different brands
in terms of like what our content is
about and it's something we grow into
but
you like anyone anyone who's trying to
be a youtuber has a harder time getting
into that because
you have way more competition yeah right
because i know that
if i were just starting youtube out
today i would be totally different
like my content would be totally
different than what i'm doing definitely
yeah and
and that's because i exist right so if i
exist then you can't do the same thing i
you can't exist in the same space that i
do right and so
one one thing that you got to find is
like a unique
way to make yourself memorable and that
might sometimes that might just be your
how you approach your content sometimes
that may be your personality
but a lot of the successful youtubers
that are rising up quickly
have found a way to make their own niche
even even if it's like this
very saturated market like i think
the person who like sticks out to me the
most recently i think of was like nakey
jakey and how yeah
and how like fast he rose and that's
because his content and the way he
delivered it was just
so unique compared to every other gaming
content out there even though
gaming was such a saturated marketing
gaming essay
outside of youtube is everything yeah
yeah yeah and i i and i would say like
that's one extreme you don't have to go
like as unique as him but even like a
lot of other people who are rising up
have found a way to make their own voice
unique or make their presentation unique
or something that is
memorable about them if that makes sense
and it's funny as well because a lot of
those types of youtubers tend to be the
most humble
yeah right because like i remember in a
nakey jakey video he once said like yeah
because i'm just jontron on a
on a exercise ball so he's that's what
he called himself he's like i'm jontron
on an exercise ball and i'm like
you shouldn't sell yourself that short
because he's completely different he's
made up his own
thing and i feel as you said that's
that's the thing right it's like
a lot of there's nothing wrong with
getting inspired
by an already existing youtuber yeah
like you know being like i like that
aspect of this youtuber so i'm gonna
take that into my own thing
but there's a difference between getting
inspired by pewdiepie and then trying to
be pewdiepie 2.0 right yeah yeah like
i think when i started youtube i think
like i definitely loved
dance videos but i just knew that like
that just doesn't work with me yeah yeah
yeah
as much as i'd love to be able to make a
gig video yeah like yeah i just i just
can't that's not that's i can't believe
it's it's a gig video because it's a gig
you kind of i think you learn a good
youtuber will learn very quickly what
tools they're working with
yeah and you can figure out what you can
kind of get out of that
yeah it's it's difficult though because
i think again like you said like
a lot of people would like specialties
are coming up now so if you want to join
something like
gaming you need a [ __ ] good skill
exactly
so think like you know if you're making
a video like is it just another carbon
copy of
someone else's or i always told myself
like let's say
even though we're in different genres
right let's say markiplier uploads a
video right at the same time i upload
a video what reason does someone have to
watch my video over his
because you know that's i mean this is
the problem right it's only x amount of
time in the day
and you need the eyeballs on you yeah so
you need to make your videos as
good as the best people on youtube
otherwise people aren't going to watch
yeah yeah like some people will
and and they'll be very grateful because
you're doing a very niche thing but in
general
you need to make your content like as
good as other people around you it
doesn't it doesn't matter how big or
small you are
this is the fundamental yeah because
everybody starts off small yeah yeah
everyone starts off small the problem is
is that the youtube algorithm doesn't
give a [ __ ] at your size i mean
i i'd say that i i i obviously agree you
should make your content as good as
possible i just don't think
especially as a small growing youtuber
making your content as good as like some
of the bigger youtubers you're not going
to but
you should have that mindset no you you
should you should eventually but
what i'm saying is like if you're
starting out youtube some of the charm
is just discovering this
youtuber who just who just like is like
a diamond in the rough right right you
shouldn't
like the quality of your videos you
shouldn't need to think that you need to
make like a jontron
[ __ ] quality-esque video right off
the bat because
like i feel like you should go
getting an each getting into youtube you
should understand what youtube
is at its core yeah cause i think i
watched like i still do i watched like
40 hours plus of youtube a week yeah um
and i've been doing that on youtube
youtube at its core isn't a [ __ ]
isn't isn't a video hosting platform
youtube at a core is a friendship
simulator oh
and i mean that's that's it is i really
want to be friends with report of the
week man i love it
i love that no because because because
because the thing is a lot of
a lot of the most successful youtubers
you know what their personality is
like and a lot of the reason why i
started watching like youtubers big or
small
small is because i like part of their
personality and
there was some like even if even if
there was someone i hated
right there was part of their
personality or part of their content
that
i couldn't stop watching or dreaming
right right and i feel like a lot of the
successful youtubers
have been able to kind of like
convey their personality into their
content in some way
it's true like that goes back to like
being like memorable and stuff like that
yeah but you know it's it's it plays
into like parasocial relationships and
all that which is a
totally [ __ ] different different
different topic but if you're talking
about success
like it's it's basically you the more
like you can become successful
successful quickly by just having people
who relates to you as a person and
that's true and
that goes into you can't please everyone
because your personality is not going to
appeal to everyone
but having your own putting yourself out
there
and if people like you or if people find
part of you interesting and you can
convey that then you will grow as a
youtuber it's true i think unfortunately
everyone can't be like
ultra mega charming right off the bat
like i mean like report of the week
i love that guys i love him um
and he that kind of personality doesn't
come along often right there's just pure
charming and like innocence yeah um but
you know like what if you have like a
[ __ ] just a normal medium boring
personality right like i feel like i've
probably had like a
boring ass person oh yeah all of our
first videos were just like
yeah but it's like developing that as
long as you're you're finding your niche
like you said like going into it like
knowing your audience like these are all
important things like you know i was
someone who was like this you know
awkward
social security and especially like as
as a youtuber i still don't feel like
i've changed a lot
i just know that hey like if i'm gonna
be like when i realized hey
if i'm gonna be a [ __ ] degenerate
let's just let's just like not let's
just go
all out i don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
anymore you know what i mean
and it's just it's just taking part of
yourselves and just
and just like going full throttle with
it i don't know i don't know because i i
agree i agree yeah
i knew i knew like that one that's just
going to make you stand out you know
like i'm now i'm not ashamed of being a
[ __ ] degenerate and i'm [ __ ] glad
that i took that change in my content
you know yeah because it just made me
like be off like it just made me less
embarrassed about being
who i was originally and like instead of
being a quiet kid
i could just talk about all the [ __ ] i
was like thinking about right
anime tv anime titties let's go baby so
bottom line
how to be a successful youtuber be
yourself
just be yourself i guess that's yeah
that's that's that's that's kind of like
one of those goes back